if the left brain interpreter is this
like explanation generation let's say
engine of sorts
um then that can be
like literally could be like papanka
might be
like the left brain interpreter like
that explanation generation engine this
mental proliferation and
conceptualization
of self and others and world and stories
endlessly and then there's the
prefrontal cortex using all of that
explanation generation to usually to try
and get something from the world to feel
whole because it feels lack
it feels separation
location etc
and then
and then and then that rumination of the
default mode network um
uh you you also set a reminder like i
like that too the default mode network
is such a reminder like there's a moment
of like peace and all of a sudden you're
being like getting reminded about the
past or getting reminded about the
future um and then there's an there's a
proliferation that happens into those
webs and then the whole thing is to just
like
yeah yeah
so cool